So there's this little marriage hack I've Learned
after being married for,
like, nine years,
and it is this,
let your man be your hero.
I know you were born into the society
where we praise boss babes
and being independent and empowered,
but let that go.
Let that go for a little bit
and see how it makes you feel.
You don't have to be in charge of everything.
You don't have to be in control of everything.
You can just let him do things. It's like,
sometimes we feel like we have to do everything,
and we feel like we have to be in control.
And if you're married to a man who is, like,
basically good,
you don't have to be like that.
It is so freeing to let go of that
and to just
sit back and watch your man do something for you.
Just let him.
It's so fun.
It's like, it's hard for me to just, like,
sit back sometimes
because I feel bad.
I feel like, oh,
I need to help out with our.
I need to do something, or, like,
I'm sorry that you did that,
or, like, a love to do things like that.
There is not a married man out there
who doesn't want to be his wife's hero.
It doesn't exist.
It's in their blood.
It's in their DNA.
To want to help you
and to want to serve you,
to want to be your hero.
And it's in Your blood to receive
and to be taken care of,
let it happen